[Music]
kevin's secret sauce these years is
artificial intelligence so yeah
gonna
drool a little ai onto this and fix the
problem kevin well i'm not going to uh
everyone else's is happening right now
as we speak and um
yeah um
and are you happy or unhappy about it i
i am happy but but i i recognize the
fact that um ai because it is going to
be the most powerful
technology in our lives will also be
powerfully abused that is that is the
rule it's it's it's going to be
it's going to make the most powerful new
problems that we have and some of those
will be the fact that it can be misused
and so we will have to figure out how
how to do that and there's people
thinking about ai safety and ai
alignment and they're all good i'm glad
they're there um
but um this issue of like um
going back to the bots i'm a hundred
percent with you john that we should
have true names only
uh people um who are speaking as humans
should be really human um but that
doesn't and and we shouldn't be um
mixing or we should be confused by um
things that are being generated by ai
but lots of times this is going to be a
partnership and that's that's where it's
going to get really hard to kind of
manage because
looking at say ai generating art
most of the really good artists are
going to be using ais as tools and these
will be partnerships and so unraveling
that degree is going to be
very very difficult for us as a society
to do it we'll have to invent new tools
to do it but um in general i think i i
don't i'm not saying that i think ai is
a solution to the social media problem i
i didn't say that i i think that um
other basic things like we just talked
about like
demanding that people be true names and
verifiable i mean even in twitter i
would like to have a function where um
i would only be able to see and retweet
blue check marked real people yeah real
people that's right that'd be huge
yeah yeah great these are the sorts of
architectural changes that i think are
important i've got another one for you
because you know your question was you
know will this will the technology help
us here will it save us quite possibly
so i've just gotten involved recently
with what's called project liberty if
you go to project liberty dot io uh it's
an initiative uh started by frank
mccourt uh who founded the the mccourt
school at georgetown
and it's a proposal for an architect a
web three based architecture on which
people could build applications and
businesses where it would be sort of
automatic that people can control
what they give out people retain
ownership of of of their own information
with currently with web 2 once the
information is out you can't get it back
but there i'm just beginning to learn
about this but i think this is the sort
of innovation the sort of
of
like
not just like what are we going to
change in twitter but what could we
change in the underlying architecture of
the entire technium
so that it's easy to build
applications that are healthy and good
for democracy and it's harder to build
exploitative manipulative ones
so you know look silicon valley is
incredibly smart tech people are
incredibly smart and now they do tend
towards asperger's and autism and this
is important it's not just as it's not
an insult this is just a fact about
different minds having different talents
and so the kinds of minds that were so
brilliant in creating these tools are
also the kinds of minds that are
least likely to understand the nuances
of social interaction and the
difficulties that their products are
causing for social interaction
so i think we need neurodiversity in
silicon valley uh but but ultimately yes
there is real hope that um that that
tech suitably you know enmeshed in teams
of people and and ideas and and
political diversity and neurodiversity
really could come up with game-changing
architectures that
bring us to this this promised land i'm
with you guys that that the tech could
in theory give us the best societies
ever the best democracies ever that
could happen it could it's not going to
happen in the 20 in the 2020s but it
maybe it'll happen in 2030s maybe it
won't be till the 2090s i don't know it
it's in theory possible and then our
challenge and it's act i know i'm very
pessimistic but when i try to end talks
on an optimistic note what i find myself
saying is
um
we have a chance to matter like the
things that we do the decisions we make
the choices we make and how we use
technology and where we invest our money
and how we treat people the choices we
make now can have more of an influence
on the future than i would say at any
point since maybe the 1930s or early
1940s this is a turning point in history
it's actually very exciting it's
frightening but it's also very exciting
and if you agree with that kevin says
absolutely
absolutely i think this is a turning
point in history yes i think i think
this is i mean we have the convergence
of all these um what you know robert um
robert gordon would say
once in a lifetime once in the planet's
uh histories we have we have these
headwinds or the tailwinds of um a.i
ubiquitous ai ubiquitous universal
connection where we're for the first
time we have
like easily for the first time ever
connected together we have the
urbanization the almost a total
urbanization of the planet which is
really great news for so many things
and um
we have these accelerants uh going on
with the youtube of learning and
disseminating science and so
um and we have other
um ones we have one challenge which in
the long term is the population
implosion but other than that i think
that that this moment will be
looked back on as an amazing time to be
alive because it's really just the
beginning of all these things and so um
i 100 that our decisions make a huge
difference and that's
one of the things i would say you know i
wrote the book the inevitable what's
inevitable are some of these things
coming along what's not inevitable is
the character of them who owns them how
they're controlled um how they're
regulated
what role they play those are choices
that we have and they make a huge
difference and so i'm totally with you
john on
this moment trying to
make the best of it right now for the
next generation
let me put the problem a little
differently to you john
what if it's turning points from here on
in
yeah that's the uh that's a possibility
and and the acceleration uh keeps
re-impacting itself
uh humanity uh does actually
collectively figure out how to either
manage or live with climate change
um
and civilization just keeps cranking on
it doesn't slow down there's parts that
slow down like north korea like spain
once did but most of it just is
increasingly global and increasingly
increasing
uh what's
what is the mode
to
negotiate and find a way to live
that way collectively if any
so that's what my book uh the book i'm
writing now is about the title of the
book is life after babble adapting to a
world we
we may never again share
and so what if it's not like cycles
where there will you know what if it's
like this
and and it just keeps getting faster and
faster and and i guess that's the
singularity
um
one of the features of this speeding up
is that we can't share stories anymore
there is no one there's no common
understanding
when 911 happened there was a general
understanding that we were attacked by
al-qaeda um and that's probably the last
time that that will happen
we can't
with the current technologies everything
is shredded social media is good at
creating little micro bubbles of meaning
but we'll never again or not never again
in in the next five or ten years we're
not going to have any ability to have
shared stories and if you tell me that
well what if it's this
i would say that we would be
so far surpassing the speed limit on
human sociality um
we can't adapt to change that fast now
there's personality differences
progressives like more change
conservatives like slower change uh
that's the wisdom of edmund burke and i
actually think edmund burke is something
everybody should read today um so uh we
might say that oh you know progress
let's go faster and faster but i think
the conservatives are right that social
order is very hard to build very easy to
destroy and right now we're destroying
it right left and center um there is
very little respect for institutions for
democratic institutions epistemic
institutions journalism science
so if you tell me what if it's just
going to keep going faster and faster i
would say
well now we're it's you know it's like
what if we've gone over niagara falls
and there's no bottom it's just falling
faster and faster in you know how you
know how water comes over then it
divides up into droplets
what is all their droplets moving faster
forever and ever and that's it
that is a vision of hell um for emil
durkheim my favorite sociologist that is
anomie or normlessness
just constant change no community no
ability to even understand what we're
doing that's that's the metaphor of
babel